de Cara a la contraofensiva que el
ejército ucraniano prepara contra las
fuerzas rusas bolodimirse lensky visitó
a sus homólogos europeos buscando un
compromiso militar adicional pero que es
importante que el kremlin sepa también
que no nos vamos a ir estamos aquí a
largo plazo seguimos firmes en nuestro
deseo de defender a Ucrania no poco
antes de esta reunión anunció que se
entregarían a kiev cientos de misiles
antiaéreos y drones de ataque de largo
alcance en los próximos meses además de
los misiles de crucero de largo alcance
prometidos la semana pasada que le
convirtieron en el primer país en
suministrar este tipo de armamento a
Ucrania en total los británicos ya han
proporcionado o prometido más de 9 mil
millones de euros en ayuda
Alemania también tiene una contribución
sustancial al esfuerzo bélico ucraniano
con más de siete mil millones de euros
en ayuda hasta ahora incluyendo una
nueva entrega récord de 2700 millones de
euros en equipamiento militar anunciada
el sábado
y del lado de Francia el domingo la
noche París confirmó un nuevo envío de
vehículos blindados y tanques ligeros
sin embargo el líder ucraniano lleva
meses pidiendo a sus aliados
occidentales que le proporcionen aviones
de combate
queremos crear esta coalición de aviones
de combates y soy muy optimista al
respecto
creo que en un futuro próximo se les
informará de decisiones muy importantes
pero tenemos que trabajar un poco más en
ella
sus aliados de La otan se han negado
hasta ahora a enviar esos aviones a
Ucrania pero lo que el Reino Unido
anunció es que un entrenamiento de
pilotos comenzará pronto Emmanuel macron
hizo la misma promesa afirmando que
Francia estaba lista para empezar a
formar pilotos de casa ucranianos